[Music]
let's see
[Music]
a gay boy named charlie attends an
all-male school and ends up falling in
love with the straightest boy in school
named nick today on cinema recap i'll
show you
heart stopper spoilers ahead watch out
and take care
episode 1 the series begins with a gay
boy named charlie who goes to his school
to start a new school year there he
meets a boy named nick a year older than
him they develop a nice friendship we
see that charlie has a boyfriend named
ben but they only see each other
secretly since the boyfriend still
doesn't want other people to find out
that he's gay one day charlie decides to
look for his boyfriend to tell him that
it doesn't feel right keeping their
relationship a secret but just that
moment he finds him kissing a girl
charlie gets very angry and decides to
stop talking to him another day nick
asks charlie to join the rugby team and
charlie accepts just so he can be closer
to nick since he's becoming his new
crush days go by and nick and charlie
train together with the other members of
the team we see that nick begins to have
feelings for charlie but he feels very
confused since he had always thought he
was straight one day after training
charlie decides to talk to his ex to
officially break up with him however the
ex-boyfriend doesn't take it well and
tries to forcefully kiss him at that
moment nick comes in and defends charlie
he thanks him for having defended him
and they both say goodbye timidly
episode 2
charlie and nick text each other and
charlie tells him the story with his ex
he tells him that a while ago he reeled
himself to be gay and that most of the
school bullied him except ben and that's
why he fell in love with him however ben
never wanted to show their relationship
later we see a girl named elle who goes
to an all-girls school as a new student
and manages to make two friends
tara and darcy one day nick invites
charlie to go to his house and there
they both spend the afternoon playing
video games and also go out to play in
the snow another day nick and the rugby
team play a game while charlie because
he's only a substitute stays out with a
friend charlie talks to his friend and
tells him that he thinks nick has
feelings for him however the friend
confesses that he's heard rumors that
nick likes tara one of l's new friends
charlie and his friend decide to meet
with elle who's an old friend of theirs
and they ask her if tara likes nick elle
says she'll look into it and the next
day approaches tara to ask her she ends
up finding out that tara is a lesbian
and darcy is her girlfriend another day
charlie decides to invite nick to his
house as a thank you because nick
invited him to his they spent the
afternoon playing the drums and when
it's time to leave nick decides to say
goodbye to charlie by giving him a hug
charlie tells this to his friends
because he believes the dog is a sign
that nick likes him while nick begins to
search the internet to learn how to know
if he is gay episode 3 a party is
organized and nick decides to invite
charlie to go with him charlie accepts
and tells his friends that he's going to
a party and one of them gets angry since
apparently they had planned to watch
movies together that night charlie will
no longer be able to go during the party
charlie and nick meet and sit down to
talk while listening to the sounds of
the music suddenly one of the members of
the rugby team comes up to nick and
tells him that tara has just arrived
the girl they think nick likes
so this friend forces nick to go talk to
her nick speaks alone with tara and
tells her that he's not interested in
her tara tells him not to worry because
she's not interested either since she's
a lesbian and also has a girlfriend nick
is relieved to clear up the situation
with tara and then meets up with charlie
again they both decide to go to talk
somewhere alone charlie asked nick if he
likes someone to which nick replies
yes but he says that person might not be
a girl charlie then asks if he would
kiss a man like him to which nick
replies
yes they both stare at each other
nervously and begin to kiss however just
at that moment nick hears one of his
friends looking for him so he decides to
run away leaving charlie alone
charlie leaves the party very sad the
next day he hears someone knocking on
the door of his house and when he opens
it he sees that it's nick who is
visiting him despite very heavy rain
episode 4 charlie invites nick to his
room where he apologizes for having
kissed him since he thinks it made him
uncomfortable however nick replies that
it wasn't like that he's just a little
nervous because he's still assimilating
being gay then nick tells him that he
wants to have a relationship with him
but he wants to have them keep it secret
for a while because he still doesn't
feel able to come out charlie accepts
this and they both kiss
the next day nick and charlie do keep
their relationship a secret but we see
that a girl begins to show interest in
nick to the point of saying that they're
already dating later a rugby match is
organized and charlie's friends go to
see him play the game begins and since
the opposing team's members are bigger
they take more advantage and one of them
ends up hitting charlie causing him a
nosebleed the game is called off due to
rain and they take charlie to the
infirmary nick visits him to make sure
he's okay and then they both start
talking about their relationship the two
get a little romantic but at that moment
one of charlie's friends walks in
causing nick to grow uncomfortable and
he decides to leave nick exits the
infirmary and meets the girl who's
interested in him she asks him to have a
date and nick feeling pressured because
his friends are listening decides to
accept we see that he's also heard by
ellen tau charlie's friends
episode 5 charlie's friends think about
whether to tell them about nick's date
while nick tries to cancel the date with
the girl but he can't because he finds
out though the girl's dog died and he
doesn't want to make her feel worse
later charlie invites nick to his
birthday party that will be on saturday
at a video game center and nick happily
agrees to go however nick realizes later
that the date with the girl is on the
same day nick speaks to his mom about
the situation he's gotten into and his
mom advises him not to go out with
someone just out of pity saturday
arrives and nick decides to go celebrate
the birthday with charlie he sends a
message to the girl telling her that he
won't be able to see her charlie
introduces his friends to nick and they
all celebrate his birthday together at
one point charlie goes to the bathroom
and his friend tau decides to follow him
when they're alone he tells him about
nick's date with a girl nick who was
going to buy some candy ends up
listening to this conversation so when
charlie comes out of the bathroom he
decides to talk to him to clarify the
situation telling them to talk to the
girl to let her know that he's not
interested in her after the talk they
decide to kiss and then continue
celebrating the birthday the next day
nick goes to talk to the girl and tells
her nicely that he's not interested in
her the girl takes it well and they
decide to stay friends episode 6
nick begins to investigate how to know
if he's bisexual since he likes charlie
who's a boy but in the past he has also
liked girls
later we see that tara publishes her
relationship with her girlfriend
announcing herself as a lesbian however
she begins to get a lot of hate which
causes her to feel uncomfortable another
day charlie stays to see tara and her
girlfriend and confesses that he is
dating nick which makes the girls very
happy the three of them decide to
organize a triple date so that tar and
her girlfriend nick and charlie and elle
and her best friend tau will go since
apparently she likes him and they want
to unite them to be a couple they go on
the date and nick charlie tara and her
girlfriend begin to insinuate that ellen
tau would make a good couple however she
ends up getting angry and when tao
leaves she tells them that she doesn't
want him to find out that she likes him
because she doesn't want to lose his
friendship later everyone goes to a
concert in which charlie tara and darcy
will participate but while there tara
hears many mean comments about her for
being a lesbian so she decides to leave
the concert very sadly her girlfriend
goes to talk to her and tells her not to
pay attention to those bad comments and
that soon people will stop bothering
them tar ends up calming down and they
kiss then they go back to the concert
just in time to start the show episode 7
nick invites charlie to go to the movies
with his friends
during the movie nick and charlie decide
to hold hands
nick's friends don't see at the end of
the movie one of nick's friends named
harry starts saying negative things to
charlie about being gay with the excuse
that they're joking which makes charlie
uncomfortable and he leaves charlie
calls his father to take him home and on
the way he runs into his ex who tells
him that he saw him holding hands with
nick however charlie decides not to pay
any attention to him meanwhile nick gets
very angry with harry for what he said
to charlie he decides to confront him
and they both end up having a fight the
next day charlie goes to school and when
he meets nick he realizes that he has
bruises nick has no choice but to tell
him that he had a fight with harry
because of the bad comments he said
later elle and tao agree to see each
other and elle decides to tell tao that
charlie and nick are dating however tao
ends up getting angry because he was the
last of the friends to find out the next
day tao texts charlie to meet at
lunchtime to talk but charlie replies
that he can't since he's meeting nick
charlie sees nick in the dining room and
just when he was going to tell him that
she'd just be friends to avoid more
conflicts he finds out that his friend
tau is fighting with harry charlie and
nick go to see what's happening and just
when they manage to separate them tao
tells charlie that he's angry with him
because he hit his relationship with
nick and that all that is happening is
his fault episode 8 charlie feels guilty
because he believes that he's only
causing problems for others the next day
he decides to leave the rugby team so he
won't see nick anymore because he
believes that he's only hurting him a
few days later a sporting event is
organized at charlie's school where elle
tara and her girlfriend darcy also
attend during this event charlie meets
his ex-boyfriend who threatens to tell
everyone about his relationship with
nick however charlie defends himself and
demands that he leave him alone later
charlie goes to talk to his friend howe
and they both end up reconciling and
agree to spend more time together then
tao goes with l to walk around the halls
and we see the tao begins to feel
something for her too meanwhile nick
plays a game of rugby but decides to
leave in the middle of the game to go
with charlie and talk alone nick
clarifies that it doesn't cause him
problems and that he also doesn't want
to separate from him since he loves him
very much and they both kiss happily
another day nick and charlie go to the
beach and have fun there nick tells
charlie that he's ready to come out as
bisexual that he's going to tell the
most important people in his life about
their relationship they both confirm
that they're now officially dating and
when nick returns home he tells his mom
that he's bisexual that he's dating
charlie and we see that his mom takes it
very well
end of season 1. if you liked the video
please leave a like and subscribe to
continue receiving the recaps of the
best romantic series on netflix
thanks for watching